Radio show radio show is brought to you
by www dot astraea magazine.
Don't come.
Professor Jordan Peterson is a clinical
psychologist,
licensed in Massachusetts and Ontario.
He's also a professor at the University
of Toronto and has been so since 1998.
Professor beaters in is currently
interested in the formula assessment and
theoretical nature of self deception,
construing it as the voluntary failure
of exploration rather than as
repression.
He's also doing experimental work on
creativity,
achievement,
personality,
narrative,
and motivation.
For the next hour,
we'll be Guy Lee.
Welcome to this edition of Astoria
magazine and Web radio.
We're delighted to have here with us
clinical psychologist,
professor Jordan Peterson.
He's going to be telling us about his
amazing book,
maps of meaning.
Now,
first of all,
Professor Peterson,
welcome.
How are you?
Great.
Could you please tell us a bit first of
all about your background?
Well,
I'm a clinical psychologist trained at
mcgill university.
I've been working as a professor.
I
taught at Harvard University in the
psychology department for six years,
and then I moved to Toronto.
I also do consulting work for a variety
of different companies.
Probably the most widely read book on
psychology for the novice reader was
young's masterpiece man and his symbols.
Are you approaching a general audience
with this book or your book maps of
meaning,
or is this more suited to the students
of psychology?
Well,
I think it's suited for people who would
like assembled and
even the ones that were written for a
general audience,
we're not particularly simple because
they're so different in conception,
but I would say maps of meaning is aimed
at the same audience that those books
were aimed at.
Other similar to two books by Eric
Norman,
who was a very astute student of youngs
and who took kills thought farther in
some directions than young had.
So I guess I see my work in part as an
extension of a young's work and Norman's
work.
I'm partly into the domain of
neuropsychology
luminaries such as when a
philosophical investigations in 1953,
for instance,
where again,
he attempted to layout the apparent
structure of the mind and the
conditioning with cultural and
historical variables.
Would that be true to say you've moved
on from that and expanded it even more
contributions?
Was the idea that was more like a a
piece in a chess game than it was like a
label for an object and
perspective.
Words were always to do things with
rather than to label things with and a
conception that I share because most of
our concepts,
scientists like to think that our
concepts are very much like theories
about object.
But in reality our concepts are much
more action oriented that not.
I mean we know for example,
that when you look at even our simple
object like a cop,
the brain areas that are involved in
motor action are activated at the level
of perception.
So for example,
when you look at a cup,
the gripping action that your hand would
make if you lifted up the cop is
partially activated merely when your
eyes a settle on the cup itself.
So,
and Vichtenstein was the first
philosopher,
although Nisha knew this to some degree
to can spend,
was the first philosopher to really
point out the functional quality of our
object categories.
And,
uh,
my work overlaps with his ideas to some
degree because one of my preconceptions
that mythological ideals,
ideas and concepts are functional.
They're to do things with their,
to act about.
They're not to label,
they're not descriptive.
Like scientific concept is a.
that's why religious mythology has to do
with morality because morality is about
action.
What is the relationship to human
consciousness in say,
the treatment of mental illness,
for instance,
of what we classify in the western
concept as mental illness?
Well,
let's,
let's start with a question about dreams
mean there's a lot of debate in the
scientific literature about the meaning
of dreams.
And perhaps there's even debate about
whether to have meaning.
I think partly the debate exists because
to do dream analysis properly as young
in particular pointed out,
uh,
you need a vast body of knowledge in the
dream interpreter about comparative
mythology and ritual and symbol and,
and art history and so forth.
Because dreams of course,
use images as their primary means of
conceptualization.
Now,
in order to understand what what dreams
mean and how they can be useful in
therapy,
apart from appreciating the fact that
the interpreter needs a broad body of
knowledge that scientists generally
don't develop,
it's also important to know what it is
that scientists have discovered about
dreams.
So for example,
we know that dreams occur during rapid
eye movement sleep.
You cycle into rapid eye movement,
sleep about every 90 minutes when you're
asleep,
when you're in rapid eye movement,
sleep,
your motor centers,
so your action centers are very much
activated in your brain,
but your body is paralyzed so that you
can't move around.
Your eyes are moving because of course
it doesn't really matter if your eyes
move while you're asleep because they
won't take you anywhere,
but if your legs were moving while you
were asleep,
you run into walls while you were
dreaming,
and scientists have actually managed to
damage the motor inhibition systems in
cats so that they do move around when
they're dreaming anyways.
If you wake up when someone's dreaming,
their brain is about as active as it is
when they're awake.
So there's a tremendous amount of neural
processing going on in the dream state.
If you wake someone up when they're
dreaming,
there's about an 80 percent chance that
they'll report the emotion of anxiety.
Dreams tend to focus on threat
processing.
Now,
a threat is anything that might hurt
you,
but it's more than that to a threat is
anything that doesn't fit into your
current conceptual scheme,
so imagine that you have a theory about
the way the world is and then you act on
that theory and sometimes things work
out the way you'd like them to work out,
but often they don't,
and every time things work out in a way
that isn't how you would like or how you
predicted that indicates that there's
some more about the world that you have
to learn about and that fact first
manifests itself in anxiety.
Now the dream focuses on anxiety and
then it loosens up.
It's the normal conceptual constraints
that characterize waking thinking and it
starts to a play in a sense or
hypothesize about how your current
categorical structure could be shifted
around so that that threat could be
accounted for.
Okay,
now that means the dream is dealing with
things that you need to understand,
but you don't yet understand,
so when you wake up and you remember the
dream,
the dream doesn't really make sense
because it's about something you don't
understand.
Now it's your brain's best guess at
configuring or understanding the
unknowable,
but it's like it's like the first layer
of a multilayered process which
eventually would culminate in fully
developed thought,
maybe over months or maybe over years,
or maybe you would never manage it at
all.
The unknown thing or the threat is just
too great to really come to any terms
with it whatsoever.
Okay?
Now imagine that you're dreaming about
something and it produces enough emotion
with the threat produces enough emotion,
not only to produce a very vivid dream
but to wake you up.
When you wake up,
you remember the dream and then you go
tell someone about it.
Well,
the dream is about something you don't
yet understand that it's upsetting and
if you tell a bunch of people about it,
they're going to give you all sorts of
opinions on the dream and that's a way
that you can gather more information
about the threat,
which is known as a nightmare.
Cynthia dream,
which is I'm traveling all puzzling
because it's so abstract.
Could you differentiate?
I think it's clearer in the case of
nightmares and often too,
because nightmares tend to have
archetipal themes.
You know?
People for example,
are often threatened by monsters at
night and a monster is a chi mirror
that's made up of the different parts of
different parts of frightening things.
A dragon is a camera,
for example,
because it's made out of reptilian parts
and it also includes the idea of fire
and transformation,
so a nightmare is that a dream that
tends to use archetypal imagery to
conceptualize a fairly powerful threat
and if you recount a nightmare to a
person with no specific training,
they're going to have some opinion about
it and their opinion might be useful in
terms of information,
Katherine,
but if you recount a dream to someone
who's psychologically trained and his
also symbolically trained and who has
great great depth of knowledge with
regards to the structure of religious
thinking and comparative literature,
the light that they're going to shed on
your dream is much brighter and more
profound.
And sometimes a,
a dream interpretation can offer the
person who's had the dream,
a leap forward in knowledge that might
have taken them five or six years to
conceptualize by themselves.
You might say that they wouldn't
ordinarily have had.
Because the person who's the expert
who's had the knows and says,
Oh yes,
I know of that place that had been to
that experience.
They've had that symbol and it's.
And the bubble,
what it feels like because of surely it
is,
um,
some people say that me included,
I'm that one way to interpret a dream
when you wake up is just to just like
you would taste a sip of wine,
just hold the flavor and,
and hold the feeling.
What does it feel like?
What does feel,
what feels the same in your real life?
And that's what the dreams trying to
tell you with a collage of singles and
memories as well that is drawn on in
recent,
I'm conscious experience to try and put
it together.
Hence the dream can be very abstract.
Would you say that's the case sometimes?
Well,
I think there's two things about your
comments that are really worth
highlighting in.
The first is
the category is that a dream uses are
generally based on emotional similarity
rather than logical similarity.
Yes.
So a dream for example,
might represent fear or the fear of
something unknown by using a
juxtaposition of a variety of images of
frightening thing.
So imagine that in the dream world the
basic rule is all things that produced
the same emotion are the same thing.
And so you're a description of a dream
interpretation process that relies on
identifying similarities in emotional
state,
gets right to the core of how dream
thought works.
Now,
secondarily,
I also believe that if you are able to
help someone or construct a dream
interpretation that fits there,
also able to feel that it fits,
it clicks or it makes sense,
or it's like the punchline of a joke in
some way they can tell that the
interpretation have,
uh,
put some missing pieces of the puzzle
into place.
And I think it's important to rely on
that as an indicator of whether the
interpretation is actually derived from
the dream or sort of just a theoretical
imposition on its structure.
Now we can go underneath that too.
And I mentioned already that basic
categories are more action oriented than
object oriented.
So basic categories,
the basic categories of the human mind
are categories to do things with.
Well,
by the same token,
there also motivational and emotional
categories.
So the primordial mind,
like the animal mind thinks sort of
axiomatically,
that all things that produces the same
emotion are the same thing.
So there's things that make you happy or
there's things that make you sad or
there's things that make you anxious and
the fact that all those things share the
capacity to evoke that emotion speaks of
some essential identity between them.
Now the identity is in relationship to
the experiencer and not necessarily with
regards to similarity between the
objects,
but it's still how we naturally think
and it's certainly how mythologies
thinks and it's how drama thinks and how
religion things.
And we've lost sight of that in part
because we've become scientifically
trained to some degree and we tend to
believe that the real categories of the
world or object and uh,
that,
that just strikes me as it's wrong.
There's something about it that's wrong
and it's wrong because we have to act
emotional reactions.
People
response.
For instance,
if you take the base emotions,
she only one could go way,
way back to the door.
Navarra beginnings when we came down
from the trees and move through the
forest out onto the plains.
Hunter gatherers and animals do share
this with us because,
uh,
the everyday dog and cat does have
emotions.
Our emotions born out of originally just
pure instinct.
Is this where the emotions came from,
do you think?
Uh,
because instinct cools is a reaction.
You have the old adage of a fight or
flight for instance,
depending on what you make a decision to
do.
Okay.
So let,
let's make a conceptual definition here.
We agree on the terminology.
Let's say that motivations are states of
being that indicated that are indicative
of a goal.
So for example,
if you get hungry,
I would say that's a motivational state
rather than an emotional state.
And it's a motivational state that sets
the acquisition and ingestion of food as
the goal.
All right?
And so there's a variety of motivational
states,
hunger,
thirst,
sexual desire,
um,
especially defensive aggression,
predatory aggression,
um,
and the desire to eliminate essentially,
uh,
the desire to play.
Those are all motivational states.
And then there's emotional states and
the primary emotional states or positive
and negative and positive emotional
states are experienced when you're
moving towards a desired goal.
And negative emotional states occur when
the goal becomes uncertain or the
pursuit is somehow frustrated or,
or interfered with.
Okay.
Now you asked about instincts,
well,
I would say both motivations and
emotions or instincts,
they're very,
very archaic if you think about the
positive and negative emotions as being
approach versus withdrawal.
Um,
animals going all the way back to single
celled organisms have approach versus
withdrawal systems.
So they're unbelievably archaic.
They go way back before,
uh,
we split evolutionarily from,
um,
our chimpanzee like ancestors.
So they are instincts and they're very
deep and they,
the fact that those instincts exist has
all sorts of strange and that their
evolutionary based have,
has all sorts of strange implications.
So for example,
you can understand the dog and
communicate with the dog because the dog
shares motivational and emotional
structure with you to great degree.
It's a pack animal,
knows about dominance,
it knows about dominant striving,
it feels anxiety and pain and it knows
how to play and he likes to play.
And there's a lot about a human being
and the dog through the same,
which is why we can live together.
But you can go way down the evolutionary
chain.
So say if you go all the way down to
lobsters,
lobsters know about dominance
hierarchies and they have approach and
withdraw systems and the lobster nervous
system,
which is very primitive compared to the
human nervous system is so similar to
ours that you can give lobsters,
antidepressants and it stops them from
feeling hurt after that been defeated in
a physical dominance dispute.
Yeah,
it's absolutely amazing.
So typically if two lobsters are in a
dominance dispute and one loses,
it will withdraw and then it'll,
it kind of folds its body up,
it,
it goes into a depressed light crouch,
whereas the winter will expand his body.
It looked bigger.
Okay.
And when the harvesters defeated,
it won't fight with any other lobster
for at least 20 minutes,
even one that it had defeated before.
But if you give it antidepressants in
the aftermath of its defeat,
it doesn't contract.
Plus it'll fight right away.
It just.
Well,
it just shows you the,
the,
the idea of,
of evolutionarily determined instincts,
in my opinion,
is not a theory at all.
It's an absolutely self evident fact.
And it manifests itself in all sorts of
strange ways.
So for example,
we know with chimpanzees,
chimpanzees basically go to war.
They're,
they're wired up to regard chimpanzee
conspecifics who aren't in their tribe
as
something to react against with fear and
hostility.
And if a wandering group of chimpanzees
say numbering three or four at the
periphery of their territory,
comes across an isolated individual or
two from another group,
they'll tear them into shreds and that
that primordial response to this
stranger sheds substantial light on how
it is that human beings demonize and
then persecute their so called enemy
resentment.
Hatred as well.
And that can be demonization is,
as you say,
is that correct?
Well,
you can break it up into two aspects.
I think,
and this is something I go into great
detail about
what the book is about.
I was interested in territoriality and
cruelty
to animals are territorial.
And if another animal
trespasses onto a complex animals
territory,
there'll be a fight.
And I think that's really understandable
because animals need territory and human
beings are clearly territorial,
territorial about our actual physical
space.
And we're also territorial about our
ideological or cultural space and it's
because we need to inhabit the physical
territory and we need to inhabit and the
illogical territory and we react to
challenges to the integrity of our
territory with fear and with defensive
aggression.
And I think that can be understood,
uh,
quite appropriately using analogs from
animal behavior and animal
neurophysiology.
But you talked about resentment and
hatred.
Well,
those emotions I think are much more
specifically human.
There's lots of examples from 20th
century history of the persecution of
enemies going far beyond what was merely
needed to ensure territorial integrity
on examples of course have that sort of
behavior abound in the Holocaust
literature where the Nazis went out of
their way not only to eradicate the Jews
and the Gypsies and so forth,
but to torment them and torture them and
crushed them in ways that were even,
that weren't even in the best interests
of the persecutor.
And that's a lot more difficult to
understand.
Treat them as no better than
animals as they called them,
but not forgetting that they were
earlier examples before when the
Holocaust.
In terms of numbers.
Sure,
uh,
and its scale and its cold bloodiness,
but if we go back to,
um,
times of say,
one of the earlier ones,
sirens that I thought were horrific
was,
uh,
vlad the impaler who used to enjoy
sitting eating his breakfast and having
his victims in paled before him.
Uh,
and that's psychopathic.
really is there a difference between
that and say,
uh,
the crimes or the Nazis.
I also think that kind of behavior is
far more normative
in,
in modern times the Holocaust.
It's sort of become archetipal of
totalitarian,
evil more than just brutality.
But my sense after having researched
this for,
for a lengthy period of time,
isn't that the whole behavior that
characterize people who were involved in
the Holocaust was
essentially normative.
And even in 20th century history,
um,
the numbers that the numbers involved in
the Holocaust per se aren't,
um,
of any order of magnitude there.
They're special.
They're,
they're not,
they're not immense by any stretch of
the imagination.
Solzhenitsyn estimated that Stalin's
brutality killed something in the
neighborhood of $60 million people.
And there's estimates from mile that he
killed 100 million people.
And in Cambodia,
we know that at least 4 million people
died
like the Holocaust is,
is that the prime exemplar of that kind
of behavior,
but it typified the 20th century and as
you already pointed out,
it's not like it arose in the 20th
century.
It's,
it's part of our,
it's part of our nature
victims into the gas chamber.
Uh,
the guy who press the release button on
the first atomic bomb fell on that
aircraft that he knew would school to
thousands or hundreds of thousands of
people because both those two people
believed in something.
Is this where it really boils down to
the difference between good and evil,
their claim that they believe in
something
to protect what they believe
in,
using the same mechanisms that they'll
protect territory.
So for example,
if you own your house and
under English common law,
you have the right to say,
and then you have the right to say,
leave.
I have a gun,
I have a gun and fire a warning shot.
And then if they don't leave,
you have the right to shoot them and you
can't be prosecuted for that.
Okay?
And everyone would say,
well,
you are within your rights because you
were protecting your territory.
Okay?
So I think people have a right to
protect their territory and they have a
right to protect their radiological
territory.
And there is rules of engagement that
could,
uh,
govern disputes of that nature.
But when you're,
there's,
there's other sorts of act and many of
those characterized behavior in the
concentration camps in the Nazi era that
can't be explained by mere
territoriality.
And that's when it's necessary as far as
I'm concerned,
to bring in conceptions to rive from
mythology,
like the difference between good and
evil.
And I think that you can define evil and
evil is an act that is designed to
produce a negative outcome for everyone
who's involved.
That includes the victim and the
perpetrator.
Because if you look at the first few
chapters in genesis is a very clear
story.
So let me tell you one of the stories.
It's really worth knowing as far as I'm
concerned.
When Adam and eve eat the fruit of the
tree,
of the knowledge of good and evil.
And the first thing that happens is that
they noticed that their naked,
what does that mean?
It means they're illuminated with
regards to their own vulnerable nature.
Because to be naked and to know your
naked is to be exposed and vulnerable
and to know it.
And often people,
for example,
will dream that they've been stripped
naked in front of a crowd.
It means their material vulnerability is
exposed for everyone to see.
The first thing Adam and eve do,
once they discovered that they're naked,
is to close themselves.
They cover themselves up and human
beings are the only creatures that were
clothes and clothes separate our
vulnerability from the natural and
social worlds.
They're protective in reality and
they're protective symbolically.
Alright?
The next thing that happens is that God
comes walking through the garden,
see in the morning,
and he looks for Adam and Adam is hiding
behind a Bush and God says,
Adam,
where are you?
I'm used to walking with you.
And Adam says,
I'm,
I'm too afraid to come out because I
found out that I'm naked.
And God says,
who told you that you were naked?
And Adam blames the woman.
Okay,
so then you think,
well,
why would adam hide from God?
All right,
so imagine God,
a
God symbolizes a transcendent totality.
And this story indicates that at some
point in human history there was an
unbroken relationship between the
transcendent totality and the
individual.
But when the individual became self
conscious,
that totality was threatened.
So why does Adam Hyde?
Well,
he knows he's naked and vulnerable,
so we hide from.
He hides from the demands of of
yesterday.
He hides from what's best in himself
because he looks at himself and thinks,
I'm nothing.
I'm weak.
I'm,
I can be easily hurt.
And therefore,
when God calls,
if I have to hide,
well,
the next thing that happens is that Adam
and eve are thrown out of paradise.
And God says,
well,
you know,
life is going to be difficult now.
Okay?
So that's,
that's the issue up.
The next chapter starts with the birth
of Cain and Abel.
Now cain and Abel are the first two
humans born in history,
right?
Because everything that happens in the
garden of Eden prehistorical human
history starts with the fall of man.
The rise of self consciousness and Cain
and Abel are the first two humans and
they're symbolic of two attitudes
towards the revelation of vulnerability.
Now,
Abel is a shepherd
and came raises vegetables,
and they're both required to make
sacrifices to God.
Okay?
Now,
why would you make a sacrifice?
Well,
it's an archaic idea.
You burn something,
smoke rises up to heaven,
God's in heaven,
and he can judge the quality of your
sacrifice by evaluating the smoke.
Let me think.
Well,
that's a very archaic idea.
And what could a modern person do with
that?
Well,
a modern person could give these archaic
people some credit first.
So let's say,
why is God in heaven?
Well,
it's because when you look at the sky at
night,
it fills you with awe.
You see an unlimited expanse of being
and that's the closest you get to
directly experiencing the unnameable
totality.
Okay?
Why should you make sacrifices to God?
Why would he be pleased with sacrifices?
While I would say you already know that
because if I asked you,
well,
what sacrifices have you made to make
things better in your life?
No doubt.
You could immediately tell me now are
people had to act that out because they
didn't really have the philosophical
conceptions and verbalized bubble form,
but they still had an intuition that it
was necessary to make the right
sacrifice in order to maintain an
appropriate relationship with the
totality of being okay,
so able make some sacrifices and cane
make some sacrifices.
Now able takes the best things.
He has an offers them to God,
so they're the firstborn of his flock
and the choices.
Cuts of meat with ables called on to
make a sacrifice.
He doesn't hold anything back.
He puts himself on the line and he
sacrifices a courageously and clearly
and cane.
By contrast,
he brings in some ratty little,
you know,
a wrinkly,
old vegetables and sacrifices those.
So God smiles on unable sacrifices and
frowns on canes.
So what does that mean?
Well,
labels making the right sacrifices.
So everyone likes him.
Is this,
his enterprises flourish?
He has good intimate relationships.
He,
he,
uh,
produces a thriving family because he
makes the right decisions and cane,
on the other hand,
everything goes wrong for him.
So this makes them mad.
It says in the Old Testament,
his countenance falls.
What does that mean?
He gets bitter and resentful and angry
and depressed.
He's mad about how things are turning
out.
So it goes and he has a little chat with
God and he says,
look,
oh,
I don't know what's going on here.
I'm working myself to the bone.
I'm making sacrifices left,
right,
and center and everything is not turning
out for me.
Like what gifts?
And God says,
pay attention here.
It's your problem that things aren't
going well.
Uh,
the,
the monster of sin crouches at your door
and you welcome it in.
You could reject it.
You could do things right.
You know exactly what the right thing to
do is,
yet you refuse to do it.
So all the trouble you're having is your
fault.
Don't come along and blame me.
Just get yourself put together properly
and do things right.
And so that's the end of the
conversation.
Well,
that isn't what cain wants to hear.
He wants to hear that the world is a
miserable place and that the reason that
he's failing is,
is because of the structure of reality.
He doesn't want to hear that it's his
problem,
so this just makes them absolutely
boiling map and the first thing he does
is go and kill Abel.
Well,
that's the difference between
territoriality and evil and he wants
what April has.
He even wants to be able,
but instead he destroys them out of
spite and resentment and revenge against
the nature of reality.
Well then God gets wind of it and mark
cane,
he says,
no one killed him,
and you might think,
well,
why?
Because it's God who says an eye for an
eye.
Well,
the next little bit of the story,
which is barely there anymore,
it's,
it's so edited out,
explains exactly why cain wanders away
and he gets married and he has a family.
But if you mess around with any of
Keynes family,
if you annoy them or bother them or make
them resentful or angry,
they don't just kill one person.
They killed seven and then those
children have children and if you annoy
them,
they kill 70.
And at the end of that acceleration of
revenge oriented killing,
God comes along and floods everything.
And that's when the story of Noah and
the Ark Kicks in,
and the story is very clear.
It says this,
if you act in properly,
and if you do the things that you know
to be wrong,
if you don't make the right sacrifices,
your life will not turn out well.
You'll be punished all the time for your
foolishness and your weakness and that
will make you resentful,
twisted,
bitter,
and murderous.
When you act on those,
uh,
motivations,
because of spite and resentment,
you'll,
you'll initiate a cataclysm of revenge
oriented killings.
And if no stop is put to them,
that will spread through the entire
society and invite the apocalypse.
And that's the second,
third major story in genesis.
Exactly right.
Would you call it moral teaching there
or was it more than that?
For sure.
You know,
I mean because it,
it,
but it's,
it's,
it's moral in a weird way.
You know,
it's,
it's more like a description of moral
reality.
Then a story that says,
well,
you should act like this because that
would be good.
If you imagine this story of Cain and
Abel,
this is a really old story.
It's been around for we have no idea how
long I'm in written form.
It's been around for several thousand
years.
It's undoubtedly part of a larger oral
tradition.
It was edited by many,
many people and told and retold and all
that's left of that story is what's
intensely memorable because otherwise it
wouldn't have been forgotten and it just
says something blatantly.
It says that
you can accept your.
You can accept the need to make
sacrifices in order to keep your life on
the right track or you can fight against
that and act improperly.
If you fight against that inactive
properly,
then you're going to compromise your
relationship with the totality of big
and as soon as you do that,
you might as well essentially you're
living in a hell if you,
if you subject yourself chronically to a
hellish existence that will make you
turn your thoughts towards really
towards revenge against existence
itself.
Well,
you know,
Stellan was setting himself up to blow
up the entire planet and there's good
evidence from the KGB archivist in the
late 19 fifties,
but he was gearing up with his multiple
pre a pre apocalyptic genocidal
practices.
He was gearing up enough courage to turn
the whole world into a conflagration.
Well,
this is no a trivial matter and the only
stories that I know that have enough
profundity to lay out the real
seriousness of the issue are these
archaic stories.
Nothing in modern culture has the
requisite profundity
magazine.
By the way,
don't forget to grab your own copy of
fascinating 40 age magazine,
just visited our magazine webpage at www
dot [inaudible] history and magazine Dot
Com and downloaded for hours a
fascinating enjoyment and do visit us
again soon because Australia magazine
don't come.
Is full of fresh news information
articles,
free audio interviews,
your very own copy of the latest issue
of Astraea magazine and also we have a
message board if you want to leave your
own news or discuss some of the articles
with other people from across the
Internet.
Www Dot astraea magazine don't coma.
No,
a trivial matter,
and the only stories that I know that
have enough profundity to lay out the
real seriousness of the issue are these
archaic stories.
Nothing in modern culture has the
requisite profundity
we do have as you get out of life,
what you put into it,
and another one that comes to mind is he
who lives by the sword dies by the sword
in the east.
They have the concept of a tradition of
Karma.
Yeah,
well,
Karma Karma is.
Karma is a really good example because
the idea behind Karma,
it's very interesting.
I think from a neuropsychological
perspective because Karma is predicated
on the idea that it is fundamentally
impossible for you to get away with
anything and there's an idea in
Christianity that's like that too.
It's a little more archaic and more
dramatic than the idea of Karma.
Now idea in Christianity is that all of
your actions and motivations are in some
manner recorded and that you'll be
brought to for them,
but and modern people look at that,
especially when it's
represented metaphorically as say,
a wise old man writing in a book.
I may just discounted entirely,
but I've certainly come to believe as a
consequences of studying what I've
studied that you you.
It is absolutely impossible for you to
get away with anything.
Whenever you make a mistake and you know
it's a mistake,
you will eventually pay for it.
You might not notice that that's what
you're paying for because often the
punishment and the crime are so distant
in time from one another that the causal
connection is virtually impossible to
identify,
but that doesn't mean it isn't there.
Now,
one of the things I attempted to lay out
in maps of meaning in some detail was
soldier and instance insights into the
processes that lead to the establishment
of the Gulag archipelago.
Prison camps in the Soviet Union were so
many tens of millions of people were
killed.
It was Solzhenitsyn's a belief,
and this is a belief that you share
Sheridan and as well,
Eric Norman,
that it was the cumulative sins of the
individuals that made up a population
that culminated in these absolute
totalitarian catastrophes.
So just as keynes unwillingness to make
the appropriate sacrifices in his
individual day to day life culminated in
the degeneration of his entire society
and the,
and the uh,
uh,
and the,
and the bringing forth an apocalypse.
So in everyday life,
each individual's moral errors
accumulate and manifest themselves at a
social level and play themselves out in
this immense,
in this immense,
a forum.
Now we don't like to think that way
because no individual likes to feel that
they're localized foolishness and
weakness.
Conscious foolishness and weakness
reverberates through the entire social
structure.
But everything that I've ever read that
was serious with regards to this subject
indicated precisely that,
I mean even Hannah run,
she wrote the banality of evil.
Well,
you know,
I think it's the evil of banality
personally,
but she,
she,
the,
the architect of the,
of the final solution was a meek,
negligible,
resentful,
nonentity.
And what that shows you is just how
horrifying it is morally to be a week
resentful,
judgemental,
non entity.
It's,
it's,
it's so catastrophic that under the
appropriate conditions it can endanger
the structure of being.
You talk about the fact that we're
comfortable with the known what is known
around which we build all our cultural
traditions and from which,
uh,
propagated,
and then there's exploration of the new,
if you like,
and how we can act on that.
Could you tell us a bit more about that?
Because you're insinuating,
I believe in your,
your work that in your book that to do
so I can make one some kind of a,
some kind of heroic action.
You,
you've mapped out something whereby we
can reach out for what is unknown to
explore a potential and creativity.
Is that correct?
That's a good summary.
I mean,
imagine.
Imagine that in life you have,
you have some one obvious thing to rely
on and the obvious thing,
you have to rely on it as the
traditional knowledge and wealth of your
culture.
It contains most of the knowledge that
you have and allows you to make your
life as comfortable as it has been made
within it.
But there are other sources of strength
too and they're more subtle.
So your culture provides you with what's
known and what's knowable,
but culture is never mapped everything
out perfectly.
There's many things that remain to be to
be known and many of the things that
remain to be known are valuable.
And what that means is that if you
search after what is yet unknown,
you can also derive strength from that
because that's the domain in which new
discoveries are made.
And so if I face you with evidence that
you're wrong about something,
which means there's something that you
don't know that you're not taking into
account that can frighten you because it
shows you that the knowledge structures
that you rely on are dangerously
incomplete and that can make you very
angry and that can make you very
resentful or you can say,
oh,
isn't that so fascinating?
The fact that something isn't known here
means that I could go and discover that
I could voluntarily encountered that and
I could derive something new and
valuable and I could use that.
And the hero in methodology is the
person who voluntarily encounters the
unknown.
And,
and this is a unbelievably old concept,
is the oldest concept we know that human
beings have created it stems all the way
back to the Enuma,
the Mesopotamian creation myth,
which is the oldest written document we
have,
and it's the Enuma elish is the story on
which the first story in genesis is
based.
Now here,
here's a way of thinking about things
and this is a mythological way and it's
extremely useful.
So forget for a minute the idea that the
world is made out of matter and forget
that it's made out of objects.
Look at it from a different perspective.
We'll say the world of experience,
which is the world you inhabit,
is made out of three things.
It's made out of the fact that no matter
how much you know,
there are going to be phenomenon
occurrences that exceed your capacity
for comprehension,
and that's always going to be the case.
And so we're going to call that a
category.
That's the category of the unknown.
And then there are always going to be
things that you know and understand,
and that's part of your tradition.
We're going to call that the known,
so wherever you go,
wherever you are,
there's a balance between the known and
unknown
and then the third thing is the fact of
you.
There's a conscious observer there and
the conscious observer is the place
where the known and the unknown
interact.
That's the mythological actors,
the known.
That's the great father unknown.
That's the great mother and the
individual and the Taoists represent
that as yin and Yang or chaos versus
order.
People think about that as masculine
versus feminine.
That gives us a bad interpretation or an
insufficient interpretation of Dallas
thought.
The Dallas say,
experiences made of chaos and order and
the proper place to stand is right
between them and you can tell when
you're standing right between chaos and
order because that's when you feel that
things are meaningful and that means
that meaning is the instinct that tells
you that you're standing in the right
place.
Now people are vulnerable and they're
afraid because of that and they can be
challenged and hurt and they can be made
angry and murderous,
but I would say,
well,
if you stand between chaos and order
properly,
your life can become so meaningful that
the meaning gives you confidence and
power and the ability to overcome your
sense of shameful vulnerability,
and I would also say that's what
religious stories or telling you to do.
Now we go back to genesis.
In the beginning,
God makes order out of chaos and that
story is based on an older architecture
derived from the Enuma Elish,
the Enuma Elish,
a god named Marduk cuts up the dragon of
chaos and makes the world out of her
pieces.
While the dragon of chaos recurs as a
mythological motifs,
frequently,
I'm generally in the guise of Leviathan
say,
and Yahuah is envisioned as the deity
that derives order habitable order from
chaos and immediately after.
Yeah,
what derives happened to Florida from
chaos.
He announces he makes human beings and
then he announces that they are made in
his image,
male and female,
made in his image.
Well,
we think that means that God is like a
human being,
but what it really means is that the
human being is like God,
isn't that the human being has the
capacity to make order out of chaos,
and when we say that there's something
divine about a person that gives them
intrinsic rights,
what we mean is the fact that each human
being can make order out of chaos means
that every single person is deserving of
a certain kind of respect.
Even if they're murderous,
even if they're criminals,
even if they're prostitutes and tax
collectors,
they're still,
they're still embodied with the kind of
dignity that only identity with God can
provide,
and that identity is the capacity to
make order out of chaos.
And it's not just a metaphor.
What's happening with those sort of
individuals is very suppressed or has it
really died?
Something in them died as spark gone
out.
That's such a difficult question.
You know,
because we know,
for example,
that certain kinds of extreme brain
damage,
criminal behavior,
if your prefrontal cortex is damaged,
then that can make you impulsive and
criminal.
From a scientific perspective,
I would say it's very difficult to judge
the culpability of certain people
because they've been damaged in some
way.
We don't really understand the limits on
their capacity to choose are compromised
and it's very,
it's,
it's a situation that has to be judged
carefully in each individual case.
But then mythologically I would say what
Solzhenitsyn said and what he said was
that in every person,
no matter how good there is,
a little corner of corruption and evil
that still hasn't been overcome.
And then in everyone,
no matter how evil and corrupt,
there's a little bit of a little corner
of good,
that's still a possibility that might be
made manifest itself.
And I don't exactly know how to
reconcile those two viewpoints.
No.
And I think,
I think each of them are right,
even though they're juxtaposition makes
them,
makes a paradox.
So looking at
read about Ted Bundy in all about Ted
Bundy.
What was that last?
I'm in the US.
Very good looking young man and uh,
he raped and murdered a number of young
women and one of his tricks was to put
on a fake cast and to elicit a
sympathetic to stop someone,
someone young and beautiful who was
driving a vehicle to use their sympathy
as a means of getting them compromised.
He was a terrible person,
but I read about his journey down hill,
you know,
and he said he first started to get
involved in violent pornography and that
as far as he was concerned,
that was what opened the door.
And I think that's a good metaphor.
I mean,
one of the things you've talked about
continually when he was attempting to
explain what had happened in Nazi
Germany was the fact that
a person moving,
moving downhill to some horrific
endpoint,
like a concentration camp guards say,
makes a little mistake,
knows it's a mistake,
little compromise and that puts them in
a position where another compromise is
more likely.
And then that puts them in a position
where another compromise is more likely
and 300 compromises later.
He's,
there's a great book called ordinary
men.
It's a study of a police battalion and
pool,
and these men started out as normal
middle aged policemen,
most of them adults before Hitler even
came to power,
so not victims of hitlarian propaganda
in their maturing phase.
They went from perfectly ordinary
policeman to men who were taking naked
pregnant women out into fields and
shooting them behind the head and
the book details their descent into this
hellish place step by step.
Well,
I think that's how people defend,
you know,
it's step by step and I believe under
most circumstances that every step is
conscious.
Even though the memory of making this
step might fade into unconsciousness and
the full cataclysmic consequences of
each moral error aren't necessarily
evident.
In the case of looking at the individual
as to the
very quickly when someone has.
What's known as a nervous breakdown is
that when they just can't make order out
of anything,
just can't cope.
They just a withdrawal.
I mean what we could look at that
neuropsychologically or we could look at
it descriptively.
So here's what happens.
Neuropsychologically there is a little
brain organ called the hippocampus and
the hippocampus helps you know where you
are and what you're doing,
and it inhibits a whole array of more
primordial emotional structures,
particularly the Amygdala and the
hypothalamus.
Now,
the Amygdala is responsible for anxiety
and fear,
and the hypothalamus is responsible for
all different kinds of motivation.
Now,
as long as you know where you are and
what you're doing,
which means that when you act,
the outcome you desire occurs because
that sort of defines knowing where you
were and what you're doing.
Then the Amygdala and the hypothalamus
remained inhibited.
Now,
as soon as things aren't turning out the
way you expect them to,
then the Amygdala is disinhibited and so
as I elements and then the Hypo,
then you get afraid and paralyzed and
the hypothalamus starts to produce a
stress hormone called Cortisol.
Now Cortisol is in some ways a
stimulant.
It'll stimulate exploratory behavior,
and in small doses it's pretty good for
you,
but in large doses it hyperactivates
your physiology,
shuts off your immune system.
It compromises your longterm cognitive
ability and it's toxic.
It starts to destroy the hippocampus and
other destroys the hippocampus.
The ability of the hippocampus to
inhibit your negative emotional
responses is increasingly compromised
and that turns into a cycle and if the
cycle gets instantiated with enough
intensity than the entire negative
emotional system can get this inhibit
and the knowledge structures start start
to become demolished.
When people talk about a nervous
breakdown,
which is usually a post traumatic stress
disorder,
chronic repeating depression,
that's basically what they're talking
about.
If you have a conversation with someone
who goes through the regular bouts of
depression,
the perception of reality is distorted.
They just see everything negative about
anything you can think about.
Yeah.
Well,
and,
and what happens is you may imagine,
imagine if you're doing some small task,
oh,
let's say you're cutting up a broccoli
for dinner and you,
um,
you cut your finger
and I say to you,
what is,
what is the fact that you cut your
finger mean,
here's some possibilities.
It means you should be more careful when
you're cutting broccoli.
Okay?
It means that you're actually not very
careful.
The fact that you're not very careful
about cutting broccoli indicates you're
probably not as careful as you should be
about most things you do.
The fact that your daughter is careful
about most things you do as you should
be,
is an explanation for why all the things
that have gone wrong in your life up to
this point have actually gone wrong.
People like you who have had lots of
good things go wrong and who aren't
sufficiently careful tend to go downhill
over time.
Plus they're very not very good people.
Maybe they shouldn't even be around.
Okay?
That's how a depressed person thinks.
Well,
what happens is that their ability to
inhibit the spread of the meaning of the
negative event is completely compromised
because they're nervous.
They're nervous system has its.
They're supposed to be a threshold for
the transmission of negative information
across different levels of abstraction.
You're supposed to be somewhat resistant
to that spread.
You know,
it could easily be that.
It could easily be true that the fact
that you cut yourself is an indication
that you're not living your life
properly,
but it isn't necessarily the first
conclusion that you should leap too,
but for a depressed person,
you know,
that's.
That's often inevitable.
They can't help it.
Slippery slope.
They're overwhelmed by chaos
explanation.
No,
you were just at a major conference on
consciousness in Arizona,
I gather now.
What new ideas did you see presented in
this field that you found interesting at
that conference?
Well,
I've been to that conference several
times and
directly relevant.
So let me give you.
Let me give you an example of
who has been investigating the mechanism
of action of hallucinogenic drugs.
Hallucinogenic drugs have been used
throughout history to produce mystical
experiences of one form or another,
and vollenweider actually provided an
explanation of why that might be.
And that was very interesting to me.
So
when you're,
your senses are each somewhat
independent systems,
but the,
the content of your sensory experience
is unified in a brain area called the
Thalamus.
Now,
so imagine you're your site and your
vision and your touch and your sense of
your body in space are all integrated in
the elements,
but there's a lot of information coming
in from all of your senses.
Okay?
Now imagine that your prefrontal Cortex,
which is a relatively new part of the
brain,
it sets up a plan what you're going to
do next,
and it tells the hypothalamus only lead
information relevant to the plan through
into consciousness.
So for example,
if you walk into the kitchen and you're
going to make yourself something to eat,
you're not going to notice the floor and
you're not going to notice the paint on
the ceiling.
You're going to notice the refrigerator
and the stove and the few implements
that you need to undertake the task
related to eating.
So the prefrontal cortex gates the
Thalamus.
Now there's a million things you could
pay attention to in the kitchen because
the kitchen is a very complex visual
environment.
Well,
if you take a hallucinogenic drug,
inhibits the prefrontal Cortex,
has capacity to gate the Thalamus,
and all sorts of sensory information
flows through.
Now,
most of the time when you look at the
world,
you hardly see any of it.
Yes,
exactly.
You're your brain is exactly as Aldous
Huxley proposed.
Your brain is actually a sequence of
extreme,
extremely complex filtering mechanisms
and most of what's out there is
eliminated well following on
vollenweider.
I would say that the ground of mystical
experience is the partial apprehension
of the richness of potential experience
beyond
beyond what's expected.
So when you look at the world,
what you see is mostly relevant to your
current plan and shape to a tremendous
degree by your memory and if if those
systems are inhibited or shut down in
some way and you have the opportunity to
apprehend what's actually there,
what's the sensation it produces,
which is the disinhibition of certain
kinds of emotion is very much associated
with what people describe as all.
No,
I would say to her,
here's something interesting in that
regard.
You know,
people say,
people ask themselves,
for example,
do you believe in God?
And I would say that's actually a
nonsensical question.
I would say whether or not you believe
in God,
you're more or less stuck with him.
He's there whether you believe it or
not,
and it has nothing to do with belief.
And I'll tell you why.
It's actually straightforward.
Okay,
so let's go back to the ancient Israelis
Israel lights.
Now they had some rules.
They believed that there was a unity
behind everything and that unity was
unnameable,
so it was against the rules to speak the
name of God.
Why?
Well,
because as soon as you speak the name of
something,
you categorize it,
and as soon as it's categorizable and
understandable,
then it's not the totality.
It's something you've parceled off and
made into a concept.
The totality of being is beyond all
conceptualization.
Okay,
so then you might ask yourself,
well,
is there a totality of being.
While the answer to that is,
well obviously,
because everything there is sums up to
one totality.
Well,
what's the nature of that totality?
it's an honorable.
You can't say it's too complex.
It's too rich.
It's,
it's not within human ability to grasp.
Is it there?
Well,
it's there.
Just like a room contains the objects in
the room.
It's there for sure.
Okay,
so there is a totality.
That's unnameable.
The next question would be,
well,
do you have a relationship with it?
Well,
the answer to that is,
of course you have a relationship with
it because every part has a relationship
to the whole.
When
you're inside the totality,
then you might ask,
well,
what's the nature of your relationship
with that totality?
And I would say,
well,
you tell me.
It's easy to know if your life rich and
meaningful and worthy of sustaining and
in your own.
From your own perspective,
do you believe that life is worthwhile?
You live it in a manner that makes it
worthwhile,
and if the answer to that is yes,
then I would say,
well,
you have the proper relationship with
the totality and if the answer is no,
you doubt the value of life.
You're hostile and resentful,
you're bored,
you're afraid,
you're hurt.
Well then there's something wrong with
your relationship with the totality.
Well,
what's what's so complicated about that?
It's,
it's,
it's self evident and it's stunning to
me that it's the subject of so much
constant dispute.
Now you might object,
well,
you have a relationship with the
totality,
but it's not a personal relationship,
which is what the ancient Israel Israel
lights are claimed,
and of course what the product Modern
Protestants claim even more dramatically
and I would say,
well,
you couldn't be right,
but let's consider it an experiment.
Here's the experiment.
Try to establish a personal relationship
with this totality and here's,
here's the criteria.
I will say that whenever you're doing
something that's intensely meaningful,
then you've established a personal
relationship with this totality and if
all you ever did were things that were
intensely personally meaningful,
while you'd live in ideal life and you
wouldn't be afraid of death and you
wouldn't become bitter and resentful,
and it's also doable.
I think with every choice you make,
you decide whether you're going to do
that or not.
It's difficult to do meaningful things.
Everybody doesn't always agree with
them.
They're kind of idiosyncratic.
There's no necessary reason that you'll
be rewarded by the culture with material
success if you do meaningful things.
Um,
so it's a shot in the dark,
which is a leap of faith,
but it's right within your grasp.
You can,
you can do it just by deciding to,
well what I learned from writing maps of
meaningless,
that the fate of the world literally
depends on the choice that each
individual makes with regards to the
relationship to the totality of being.
And that's that.
And that's what,
that's the central message of profound
religious system says there's more to
you than you think a lot more.
There's more that,
more for evil,
way more than you think,
and there's way more for good and
whether you know it or not,
you're always choosing between those
two.
And whether you know it or not,
the fate of being itself rests on your
choice.
Well,
who the hell wants to believe that?
Wait,
it's too weighty.
I don't care if it's way too.
You're not.
When you're trying to investigate the
reasons behind something like the
Holocaust,
things get weighty very rapidly.
No,
that was a group experience.
It wasn't an individual,
a just purely individually experience.
How do you think
we handled that?
Well,
I think you can think of two recent
events.
Nine slash 11 would be one and the
flooding of New Orleans.
So with regards to nine slash 11,
the most interesting thing to note about
people's responses to that catastrophe.
Was there an unconscious need for
repetition?
I mean everyone I know watched the trade
towers fall 50 times 100 times in shock,
uh,
unable not to watch.
And I think the reason that that's so
illuminating is because it shows you how
complicated it is to see what you don't
understand.
So mythologically speaking,
the fall of the towers was equivalent
both to the death of the king and to the
reemergence of chaos.
And when the king dies and chaos
reemergence,
it's very difficult to see what's there.
And I'm not speaking metaphorically
precisely.
People wouldn't have had to watch the
towers fall over and over if they could
see them fall and on a trivial level,
a building collapsed.
But what the events that characterized
nine slash 11 were far more than merely
a building falling when the event
happened.
No one knew what fail.
No one knew if the financial system
fail,
no one knew if the economic system fail.
No one knew if the world order had
collapsed.
And everyone watching those buildings
fall was trying to perceive all those
others have levels of reality at the
same time.
Well,
that's really,
really complicated.
Well,
and then Bush offered people in easy out
in a prepared way out.
He said,
well,
the people who did this were evil and
perhaps they were the people who did
this.
We're evil,
we're good.
There should be a war.
Now,
as far as I'm concerned,
well,
that's a mythological explanation and
it's,
it's very easy for people to instantly
put forth a mythological explanation
when chaos makes itself manifest.
Well,
of course,
the problem with our response to nine
slash 11 was that almost every bit of it
was a lie.
Um,
we know that the American government
utilize the events of nine slash 11 to
justify an invasion on Iraq that had
been planned at least 10 years before
that historical documentation of that
is,
is available from the people who did the
planning.
They're still part of bushes,
government.
So
you asked about our response.
Well,
you can't,
I mean,
I think when,
when Bush went into Iraq,
people,
I had a legitimate debate about what
should be done about tyrants like Sadam
Hussein because he was obviously a
horrible person and his sons were even
worse.
But the idea of that
catastrophe consisting of the
reemergence of chaos could be met by
dissimulation and conscious lies and
that,
that would work out successfully.
Well,
that's,
I would say that's willfully blind,
a corrupt and naive all at the same
time.
And that's what characterized our
response,
wasn't that response plan by a group who
were disciples and followers of a
philosopher called Strauss,
is that correct?
Yes,
that's right.
That's right.
And,
and they had put a manifesto together
back in the mid 19 nineties
had written Clinton expressing their,
their need to invade Iraq.
Um,
which,
which I don't really think is the issue,
like I said,
because Saddam Hussein was a terrible
person and it isn't clear that the
international community exactly knows
what to do with barbaric dictators.
The problem wasn't necessarily the idea
that going after Saddam Hussein was
justified.
The problem was that an event that had
absolutely nothing to do with him was
utilized in it absolutely deceitful
manner by people who had a preexistent
agenda to deceive their entire populous
and to justify and to use that as
justification for doing something that
they had other reasons for doing it.
When the,
when the justification for judging,
it seems that you have to be in order to
be able to judge as in Nuremberg,
the victors judged,
uh,
the judge saying,
you know,
they put him on trial.
But otherwise,
as you said,
the world community,
you don't seem to know what to do
otherwise with a,
it seems complicated
problem,
right?
I mean,
it's part of the problem we're talking
about is what's the appropriate response
to the manifestation of evil.
Well,
I would say generally speaking,
evil is something best corralled in your
own life.
And once you more or less corralled in
your own life,
if you have in fact manage that because
that is a very,
very difficult thing to do.
Well then maybe you have something to
say about it on a social level.
But,
um,
we,
we con
people,
put the cart before the horse and many,
many individuals who are unable to make
peace in their own house are perfectly
willing to go out and try to make peace
in the world.
Well,
there's more Brisson ideology and that
then there is intelligence.
And,
and,
uh,
and portia,
and this is something else you want to
add about either Jordan or whether you
want to talk more about you ideas you're
working on.
Well,
there's just a,
just one thing I wanted to have.
I mentioned nine slash 11 and New
Orleans.
Yes.
New Orleans
is another example of the death of the
king and the reemergence of chaos being
the same thing.
The chaos in genesis is watery and it's
watery chaos that causes flood.
And the flood that God caused with
regards to Noah was the reemergence of
chaos because of a corrupt social order.
On the same thing happened in New
Orleans,
on the one hand it was a storm,
so the storm caused the flooding,
but on the other hand,
had the levies been four feet higher,
there wouldn't have been a catastrophe.
So the fact that there was a flood of
New Orleans is as much evidence that
order was insufficient to hold chaos
back as it is evidenced that the chaotic
hand of God is perfectly capable of
causing natural disasters.
Exactly.
And it was not just disorder but
corruption,
right?
So it's archaic cultural systems,
the,
the levies there were too old and
starting to deteriorate.
So there's,
they deteriorate of their own accord.
Plus the deterioration is sped along by
the fact that the people who are
punitively in charge of them aren't
taking their responsibility seriously.
Metaphor.
That reminds me in Australia,
on the beaches that have been shark
attacks where they have short sentences
in the,
um,
in the sea which has not been repaired,
and there are holes in the fences are
getting through and attacking surface is
the same.
The same
example
popped into your mind is because of the
mythological equivalence you see,
because the underwater creature,
that terrible human devouring underwater
creature is a prime,
mythological,
cool representation of chaos.
So for example,
a mat in the Enuma elish who's basically
the model for the Leviathan is an
underwater drag,
an underwater devouring dragon,
and she's the prime symbol of chaos.
And so I would say your example was
brought to mind by the mythological
equivalent between the two,
between the two occurrences
hearing you discuss your ideas and your
work maps of meaning.
Could you please tell us where this book
is available?
Well,
I would say the simplest place to find
it at Amazon,
if you go to my website,
which is maps of meaning Dotcom,
right?
There are lectures on the book televised
by Canadian Public Television and,
uh,
links to places the book can be
purchased.
So that's probably the simplest thing to
do.
You'll your,
your,
um,
lecturing,
or are you touring or what's happening
now?
Well,
I've written recently a few papers on
the nature of self deception,
which is a very paradoxical concept.
Um,
self deception implies that at least in
its classical formulations that a person
knows something and doesn't know
something at the same time,
which is a problematic conceptually for
a variety of reasons.
I've been trying to crack that problem.
Um,
I've also been attempting to recast our
models of neuropsychological
functioning.
I'm starting from the presupposition
that what the mind encounters is much
more properly conceptualized as an
information rich matrix of relationships
than it is conceptualized as a place of
material objects.
And that's following to some degree the
ideas of the physicist wheeler who was a
student of nails for I believe,
who,
who has hypothesized that the
fundamental elements of matter are more
like bit more like computer bits of
information than they are.
Like something classically material.
The causes is the events that happen.
Well,
it does seem related to that in some
manner
that I described earlier about the
capacity of human consciousness to make
order out of chaos.
I personally believe,
and this is partly because of what I've
learned from reading religious
mythology,
that human consciousness realizes the
world in some non metaphorical sense.
I cry,
I'm not a materialist,
and I truly believe that if human
consciousness did not exist,
the idea that there would be existence
is in some manner wrong.
I think existence is dependent on
consciousness and I've been trying to
work out the implications of that idea
in a scientifically rigorous manner and
that constitutes partly what I've been
writing about recently.
Granted,
if you can sit here and talk about,
let's talk about,
for instance,
think of the first world
war
and we think that this happened,
that happened,
et cetera.
You can think about the great
depression.
Neither you nor I were alive at the
time.
Yeah,
but we take it for granted that it
happened.
Now,
if you go from now,
today and you go forward 100 years,
neither you nor I will be alive then,
but that shouldn't worry us should it?
Well,
I would say that the are being would
still be embedded in the matrix of
reality,
right?
Because the things fulled up in a way
the past folds up and it's still present
in the present and the future is not yet
unfolded.
Implicit in the present,
and I would say just as none of your
deeds do you just as you cannot escape
from the consequences of any of your
deeds,
the record of your being and the and the
nature of that being is embedded in the
fabric of reality permanently,
possibly what we can of a manmade
abstraction.
Maybe there is no such thing as time.
Well there is for us and what that means
in some ultimate sense is obviously not
a conceptually accessible to us.
I think that's part of the reason why
it's possible to realize that the
implications of your behavior and your
conceptions reverberate far past you.
Things are not necessarily precisely
what they seem.
Professors
has been marvelous discussing these
subjects with you and listening to your
views.
I'm sure our listeners will find is most
interesting.
And on behalf of all the staff here at
Austria magazine,
they'll calm and Astria web radio.
I'd like to extend our thanks.
And we hope that,
uh,
you'd be able to submit an article for
us at some stage if you wish for our
magazine in the due course of time.
And maybe you'd like to come back for
another discussion at some point in the
future,
but on behalf of everyone here,
thank you very much for this most
fascinating discussion.
Thanks very much for the opportunity.
Thank you professor Jordan Peterson.
Well also have of.
Well that brings us to the end of this
show.
Thanks for listening and we hope you
enjoyed it.
Do join us regularly for all the latest
ideas,
news reviews and discussions and free
audio downloads an Australian magazine
with radiohead.
You'll right click to knowledge and
discovery.
You might also want to download our
feature bank Australia magazine in
Australia magazine,
has got 40 pages of high quality
articles by well known authors,
scholars and progressive thinkers,
and it only cost a trifling three pounds
studying or a couple of dollars or so.
Simply purchase your download via our
secure protecting pay pal system and
it's yours to print out and keep.
We're sure you'll have hours and hours
of enjoyment and fascination reading
Australia magazine.
So just go to our magazine page and grab
your very own copy.
Www Dot astraea magazine.com.